The Joe Rogan Experience I think it's
5-0 I think five zero I think five zero
I think that's the new middleweight
champion in the world that is [__]
crazy you got there's one round where
Izzy might have won might have but I
don't think he did all those significant
strikes that's all nonsense you're
looking at leg kicks that get checked
you can't count those as significant
strikes that was amazing so what do you
do now say Strickland wins this what do
you do Hamza still no yes it's a rematch
automatic rematch right you gotta have a
rematch Izzy's
Conor McGregor the the rematch is in the
in 100 the big money and that's what
would be smart to do agree
and do policy's like okay
wow Izzy doesn't want to hug him
yeah they don't like each other well he
likes him less now he just took his
[__] world title
please replays look at that Darkness see
him knock his hand out of the way
hold his hand right out of the way these
MMA experts are bringing up their
[__] tweets we have a two to one or
out of their [__] mind what what two
rounds would you give to Izzy oh they're
out of there get the [__] out of here
they're out of there I love Vizio as
much as the next game you can't find Two
Rounds I mean this was wild I think
everybody look at that Jab
we just watched history that's a huge
upset huge biggest effort and
Championship rounds look at this look at
this is it look at this look at the end
of it come on let's [__] go front
kick to the butt and Izzy can't do [__]
about it just that alone just that alone
is crazy to watch yeah talking [__] come
on you [__] [__] he's saying come on
you [__] [__]
look at that leg kick landed here we go
give me some volume Jamie this is crazy
give me some volume
let's check a little guy about to cry
unbelievable insane he [__] crazy
I've ever seen that wild mother
middleweight champion of the world God I
wish I was there I wish I was there for
that
good for Izzy too good friends yeah
yeah but he's is he's is he so great get
a microphone on these guys yes
dude if I was there yeah
what is that tattoo of
oh it's his friend he had his friend's
photo uh tattooed on him and Sean
disrespected it and he's like it was my
friend he said oh look at that that's
beautiful that's beautiful
you gotta love that dude I love that I
love that how can you not love it good
class class and defeat holy [__] let's
hear what this wild it's about to get
wild
what world are we living in look at in
Australia you gotta love
him yeah
look at his face he didn't get touched
not touched he didn't get touched he got
like a couple of Jabs snuck in and
barely touched him that kicks didn't
count
powerful
how great is Daniel Cormier how about
Nick sick with the game plan wow
he [__] did it he's got the UFC
middleweight championship title around
his weight he be his ways he beat the
best ever in his prime would you have
called that beginning of the year
Strickland's me middleweight champ like
get the [__] out of here after he's lost
never how he's gonna be two random dudes
and then get a time out of your mind
unbelievable